okay ladies and gents so now we are going through july
kind of get straight to it sure okay so july
we've shifted polish
honestly like i said i'm not a huge fan of these large price ranges
i prefer kind of smaller price likes from these large price ranges open up to
more
potential mistakes but without further ado let's go ahead and get into this
okay interest in price action
so
we've shifted bearish
so this technically becomes the continuation however if you guys remember
i'm not a huge fan of this so i'm going to take it but i am going to flag it
for review
because these specific setups if you remember the continuation models when you
've swept
some price already down here and then it's just this like but i will take it
and flag it for review
could get away with it just playing them momentum continuation but i'm going to
go initial balance
from here and out ever trade is initial balance let's see
technically tags us of 503
i still want to see how it plays out because i want to understand if this is a
good setup or not in general
still wouldn't it be break even and these setups are not ideal
but you can see here as well this management principle something that i really
want to add
price comes in gives a reaction doesn't warrant going break even but now you
put stops above here
now you put stops above here which is probably 0.3% price comes in texas at 0.3
% and then starts
going and the moment you might like pissed but then it comes back up for sure
and hits this and so
instead of taking a minus one you take minus 0.3% well if you do that you know
three out of 10 times
on average over you know 200 trades um you don't have a drastically better
performance
sees small details that make your edge right it's trust me management is
arguably the most
important part of your edge and that's that
okay interest in price action Tuesday 4th of july i think 4th of july is like
an important
day in america if i'm not mistaken it's like independence day or something
so we yeah i'd be very cautious of low volume especially in new york session
yeah you can see it
um so we're next day
which is the fifth
i don't know what the rest of water on that's going to be
okay
maybe get away with something like that it's 4th or a hmm it does tag
so
i already see the chance to go to break even
we can reduce 0.2% at worth of risk
like we can cut 0.2% of risk
it's 5r wait a second
i don't know if there's any scale and opportunity that was missed in new york
that i didn't look at
technically not
unless it went internal because that is a really nice point of interest
so you'll be trading london new york continuation from here 5th of july
no news
and you go what pretty much because the external is all the way from here to
here
and so instead of going external you go internal
so instead of going external you go internal
which is bullish which becomes bearish
inside of our area of interest as well
again this is some people might not trade london right i need to collect the
data for both
some people may not be trading the london session some people may only be
trading
this new york session and although it exposes me to double the risk you know
maybe in a live
environment maybe i don't take this maybe i don't take the london one i'm not
saying what i'm
going to take i'm not going to take i'm just saying that maybe i do trade l
ondon and new york
maybe not but the data still needs to be the data still needs to be collected
because
the people are trading multiple variations of this
of this system
it's not really enough about the breakeven but
which is 0.1% there you go so when price comes back in and mitigates this and
then
continue trading lower that's for me when breakeven now makes sense
and same here right
i'd probably say
not breakeven but i was a
it'll be in here so there's a lot of risk reduction which again is
one of the most important things that i'm interested in
the most important thing is that it's not a lot of risk reduction in the market
.
um
nice that's a much better stock than
then what we're trying to do where was it
where was the first sale
here for example because this actually sweeps liquidity it sweeps this and then
shifts
and the new york as well okay let's go through one by one what is that in net
oh that one is 5% that one was 7.5% i think it's 12.5% it's an incredible start
this is the 86 lot one yeah that's the first one
so this is the london sweep london sweep asia this is coming from
where's our n15 structure
so this is technically a strong point of interest as well we have
highs lows we have a break of structure in here
and then price is trading from you know a kind of cluster of orders that are
inside the price
like the price price lower i think it may actually just sweep this level it
does some liquidates that
which means it's really probably comes from this one
which again still strong strong areas of interest of contribute with the break
of this law
so
price reaches these levels doesn't really make much of a difference
okay that's the 86 lot short then you also have the new york short
this is new york continuation from london area of interest
point of interest is still such strong one session at new york structure flow
is internal
per trend
okay which takes us to london so we're obviously
bearish
not like a shift
is a shift
cluster bear
so pretty much just looking at this cluster here
right and five
make sure we don't have any news six of july
not right now
technically can't reduce risk now we can so that comes down from being you know
or a whole percent to point two five percent
there's the mitigation and look at that again
could have been a one percent loss ends up being a point two five percent loss
that will go down as a loss meaning that we took two trades just a moment ago
right in july without two trades two winners one loser technically a 66 so win
rate
however the average win to average loser on that is like
like 20 times more player more
it's 25 times more player but it's the same thing that's so I'm really
and I guess you wonder what right there are you I went to a time of love again
we don't need to help my stops at these highs
probably have an unfinished or probably have a finished auction at those highs
that only is a one to three
okay even in here like
maybe a management system could be to put my stops there instead of taking a
four
one percent if it runs through that was point four six all right especially
after you get
rationed like that all of a sudden you've just reduced the the loss right
and the rule is it's an easy rule to create
you
okay and you want to use this this section this session section
for just things ideas that you get that come to you oh I keep seeing this maybe
that
oh maybe this maybe that that you can't integrate right now into a testing
because
you're testing specific hypothesis the member that you start changing things
mid
testing that's when all hell breaks loose you know
I have no idea where that 815 candles come in from
I have a feeling that it's going to be ADP
but shouldn't ADP be two days before
I don't know
wouldn't have attacked if I did take this anyway
um bristle bearish a lot of buy side across you
well that's 100% of entry
I like this cluster here
would have been nicer if we take this high out
you
keep moving it and pointing but to the same place
uh the day is
Friday so we may have an FP okay we do have an FP
so i want to be very cautious of trading
so
here we go for doing
gain good management
the
can already see the order flow inside of price
again many of you probably already are familiar but
I'm working with a pretty high level institutional grade trader at the moment
um just on the same issue like you've invested into this program
do you invest into your skillsets i'm still investing into my skillsets like
I don't believe that you just um
I don't believe that you just
learn an edge and then you just done and then you just trade that edge forever
now i believe in the constant evolution of one's ability to do anything in life
so i'm still continuously investing into my skill set my edge my read in the
market
like i'm such a better trader today than i was you know in 2023 still
profitable but just
better and i want to constantly become better so now i'm learning from high
level
institutional trader to to learn and read level two data
i'll release a program at some point on it it'll probably be like a kind of
higher tier program where traders who are already seen levels of success with
with this sort of stuff can move into that advanced program
but we look at level two data because it can confuse you if you're not already
a good trader
but i can already see the order book so that level one data is your candlest
icks
level two data is inside of this candlestick you'll see the actual orders
right the actual auction and i can already see that this is a finished auction
and i can already
see that this is the high volume area and so i already knew that this was the
the perfect area
you've seen me many times i put my stops like here and then i was i was doing
this i put my stops at
eight so i put my stops at eight and i kept on bringing it down i was like i
can probably bring
my stops down and the reality is i could have brought my could have most likely
brought my stops down
here because this is the this is the high volume area
this cluster here it's the high volume area from before and it's high volume
area again
but that's i don't want to fry your brain right now that's a whole other ball
game
that just doesn't need to be discussed right now
um it's also technically a weak point of interest
although maybe not because it internally internal break
it's a technically a strong point of interest
so
so we're looking at the long continuations
same here like it's riskier but these are finished auctions the high volume
area is here
but i wish i can't see the level two data right now this is a little bit more
difficult
like you want to you know the goal is put your stops below lows and highs but
if i can put my
stop below a low here for example this makes it a 4.6 instead of a 6.6 right it
's an actual like
what is the 30 percent more 40 percent
somewhere in that region 35 percent if i add an extra 35 percent of
profitability
but it has to it can't be guesswork it has to be like not accidental
and i can't see that as clear of this one as someone prior to be like to be
totally honest
we'll see how this plays out i don't want my stop to be open
okay that almost very nearly gets me in trouble yeah i'm we just took a break
even right
and all the rules are followed
cool um how does that play out
stop was here so the stop was respected
we get a break even did we get a break even yeah we must have
or did we take a smaller
i took a small last i think yeah we did
what was it 0.6
gain price mitigates has a reaction
0.5
and then just and even that reaction you could get technical and you could
start moving it up
i'm not gonna have to do that in the moment
and then it ends up running toward target after taking us out
but the thing is in this specific scenario it doesn't hit far far anyway so
that's one of those where it's a little bit like
right on a different day it could have hindered us
but it's also the reality of love markets let's see what we get in new york
10th of july
10th of july there's no news
I'm playing it so just don't say price
type goes in yeah it's fine
some days that's just how it goes
well we're very much bullish
hmm that becomes a continuation higher which i don't like
that becomes a change of character technically
that becomes a new structure high
and then we continue bullish anyway
some in sometimes the market will give you these pullbacks and really you can
see that
it's not part of the price leg but you don't really have a way to kind of fully
determine that
like for example if this if we didn't get induced by this pullback here's three
candles right
yeah if we didn't get induced by this pullback we would have been able to take
these longs
here sometimes that's just how it goes obviously but if we would have been able
to take these
longs that's like i'm doing this to show you that just the reality that's ao
the reality is is sometimes you're going to get it where it's not favorable to
you
sometimes you're going to get it where it is favorable to you right that's just
that's just
probability is playing out uh 12th on Wednesday we have inflation right
this is technical similar and yeah i was never going to get into one of those
trades also
still not going to trade that i don't think
nope Thursday 13th
ppi
yep no trade next day swing lowers asia i'm not interested in that so i'll just
sit on the side
if i have to that technically becomes a change of character
although i would have much preferred to have long and use my discretion as you
're already now
but even if i had we wouldn't have a trade so it's fine but yeah i'm not want
to use
asia's session lowers by swing point it just makes no sense um it's technically
not a break
until there's a lot of liquidity
so we would be technically bearish but i believe the price of trade higher
i would honestly prefer for price to trade higher it does
no the turnip the swing highs here so now we become bullish that's why would be
more sided with
current i'm not going to long until we do that
sweep the law monday it's probably going to be no news
is that a shift yes but it's already outside the window
i'm going price is a little bit choppy nice
okay that's the price section
running to here with the ideal
still not for work
so we can look at long in here not yet but retail sales probably not going to
trade off the back
of that that session done done so we are still bullish probably not going to
get a yeah
so now we're bearish
still bearish which means
could technically trade that now
okay let me check the stroke drawer
sometimes you have to check the structure sometimes it's just obvious you will
probably
develop that ability the longer you trade
the key the key giveaway by the way to understand whether you're kind of
you know for sure that it has to be is when let's say you're in a price range
right and you're kind of at the low of the leg like it's and you can see that
price was
the last kind of potential high swing points on the m1 were like up here and
then you get past
the area where it's like okay now everything below that low is obviously
structured and then
there is pullback criteria below that obvious low that's where you just like i
don't even have
to check because it's just obvious but sometimes in this scenario for example
you're not past the
obvious low like we could we don't know if we're coming from this high or a
high up here for example
or even a high up here right it becomes different for example like we've gone
past this low right
we've gone past you know this low and then we have a low like this and then
price starts coming
back like that well now all of us and it's obvious that these are our structure
points
but we don't have that that's what that's why we now need to go and figure out
where's the pull work
so now we become bullish up here you see so that will technically be
hmm could argue to use m1 internal what is it 19th
the 19th it is the 19th could technically go m1 internal and the reason that we
could go m1
internal still be we'll tag a discretion and then add the note so it's m1
internal but it's
because the actual m1 swing low to shift bearish is the m15 low which is the
target
so confirmation would make the trade void right hopefully that makes sense
so you could technically go to internal for example and then internal you could
see that we have
three candle pull back here so then we break that high we come up
have three candle pull back here
we break that low high volume area is here
probably get where putting stops up here but again we'll still want to cover
the high again
could easily cover this high but yeah honestly you easily could cover that high
and then you you play that
then it will it will still be quote-unquote discretion hopefully that makes
sense like it
doesn't look like i'm just pulling price back like it's still discretion we're
still going to
tag it but it's using internal instead of external
like the moment that happens you pretty much put your stuff here anyway
instead of being a 1% risk we now got the risk down to 0.2% and we end up
getting tagged out
right so that's still again you can see like i care about using the
okay about the data not the outcome it's still a sir it's a little bit of like
a
weird one but that's why it took me a while to catch it but
again risk mitigation how many times we've taken the losses that could have
been a 1% loss
that ended up being you know 0.2% 0.3% 0.4%
it's also kind of in some way like a strong point of interest
i guess it's a little bit of a it's a weird one maybe we consider it broad
it's not an easy read it's not a clear black and white
we'll call it strong
because point of interest that breaks a low above Asia high
this is a weird one this is the first time we've had the trades up like that
again honestly at this point i just don't even think premium discount really
matters
okay this goes to New York
it's a really weird price action
it doesn't break the high it's a good thing
which means
we're now
wait let me just
so that's a technical change of character right
is that right or wrong yeah that is right does it change character yes
which means that's a technical break of structure
which means that's a technical change of character
right and there's no pullback in here
which means this is the low
which means that's a change of character which means we technically can trade
that
that specific model that we that we don't like uh wednesday 19th
building permits already passed i don't really know how to get into the market
here
i don't see like specific area we could use this m1 level
probably put my stops here which is going to be a very unfavorable risk to
reward
I don't really see the point in trying to use the m5 power you got
i feel like it's just really trying to force the idea of a trade but it's the
only thing that gives the rest reward
again these are some of the decisions you're gonna have to make in the moment
sometimes it's obvious
but this is like more nuanced the reason i'm using this area is because the
rest reward is just terrible using this cluster here i i don't think price will
return back to here and then continue but it's does it matter what i think
to some degree yeah i don't want to completely write myself off because i'm a
very very good trader
my analysis is very very good my understanding market's very very good but
now i think price one ties
again could have had a much greater management here right like i see the same
thing again
i keep seeing the same thing over and over and over again
this is how you develop rules this is how you develop an edge it's like i'm
seeing price come
into the level it's having a reaction now i don't need to keep my stop here
because we've mitigated it prices that need to come back above this high and
then trade lower
we're collecting the orders if if supply cannot move price lower and demand
steps back in
then the order flow is obviously bullish and so if this high is getting taken
out there's a
very good chance this high is getting taken out and that's a huge difference
right that's the
difference between you know a average loss of ten thousand dollars and an
average loss of five
thousand dollars right this entire leg is that's fifty percent decrease
mitigation of
a risk i reduce 50 percent of risk every time that i'm able to do that and
successfully and
how many times if i keep seeing it play out to the point where could have done
it could have done
it could have done it right and so i would i would implore you to go test that
i will personally
look at the the review and of each trade and incorporate that in my refinement
process but yeah
like i'm seeing it over and over and over and over again why is that two trades
with the exact same
amount of loads
because we have the same stop size just wanted to make sure i didn't excuse the
same trade twice
this would be like a low
a low continuation
again for me it's like this model has potential but this model needs to be
reversed and
not here where there's liquidity and there's imbalance in price what needs to
happen if i'm
trading this model is that it needs to happen up here the the low sweep and
then the continuation
needs to be here as price is falling not when price has already fallen and then
trying to get
involved in this leg to go lower when there's inefficiencies i want to see
price running to
here and then do it right so there's going to definitely be a refinement in
this specific model
to make it even more profitable gain
in this specific scenario we'll just get really really unfortunate to be honest
with you
yeah we'll just get really unfortunate sometimes it's going to happen
but definitely could have made a risk there without a doubt her point of
interest is like just
broad i guess
i don't really know
session
it's really interesting price action in here to be honest with you
you
no news
i don't like that so it's like unfinished auction
i don't think i'm short from here let me have a look at the
the ratio award i'm probably short from the lower if i was to excuse this i
might again
i don't care about the data in the back testing i don't care about
profitability per se i don't
know i would excuse that i care about just the data of the model man
like it's really really important that you're able to do this subjectively
like i know so many people that just kind of delude themselves in back testing
it's a real
thing but you may have even done it yourself before like i would been guilty of
doing it myself
like when i first started out you you want to make things fit right so you
start changing things
start adding things in start i don't know about that one you must detach from
the outcome
the reality is that um i don't like that look what it is at the top the the
reality is
let me play this right now
i would like to go to break even
whoa
i will go to break even the reality is is the
um you care about the model you can't make him money
trying to get as close to as close to uh like five r as possible
oh that was perfect
original position 50 percent i just need to make sure that it's at 336 so the
execution
oh let's take profit level because i'm uh i'm looking out
and then eight for two six and a half percent
starting to get our numbers back up i think july has been uh high
i really can't talk and do both kind of
i know it's an empty leg and strong points of interest for this model
a way better the interest i
yeah i think the the win rate and overall return in this month has been like on
point
so we're over 10 percent return this month
just now it's gonna bring us more clarity
i'm here
i'm not sure i hope not
no okay good
so just to be clear the swing high is still here
it's 24th
whoa whoa whoa
um h-carber 330 i don't want to be involved for that
okay now i want to get involved though
oh no chance really really nice if i would have been able to have time to get
involved in that
um let's go to new york session because probably pretty pointless
okay 20th here
it's got to be a shift in there so all i know
okay there is not there is not
nope really nice nice price action just no entry
new york may retrace us back but yeah probably not
London do you think we got a reversal here
but our swing low is down here i'm not a huge fan of this price action i would
probably
assume lower prices personally but could be completely wrong 26th we have fed
interest rate
which is a new york session yeah if i was to long this i would have to be below
age low so
nope
uh still can't long this really
i'll need that age low to be taken out to be totally honest
um yeah i was wrong we have another age low i think
oh wait
no perfect so you can sweep age alone long from here that would be great
27th we have durable goods and GDP and interest rates okay it's going to be an
aggressive new york
session that becomes a swing low
and that's the aggressive new york session interesting i come back to this time
come back to this specific area so many times
okay
that's so annoying
that means this is a swing high which i just don't like
we have core pce personal spending personal income
we have a bunch of euro news in london session so
we have some news i'd probably just leave it
probably leave this day in general that's just brought us a bunch of news here
as well
um and then we are bullish there's not going to be an opportunity so long but i
think no cool
final day of this month
that's not pulled back so first we have let's see a bunch of news again in in l
ondon session
so um
what times our first news event
so first first news event is a four what time is that two forty five and maybe
a trade in here
i'd prefer there wasn't
okay so all of this is
which means
which means we want to shift bullish when we break this high
which happens here which means turn a clip in me
and five and three and two and one yeah inverter value up
that's the area that i would look at trading from
my stops are safely put them below that bar again five point two six adds on
extra like
basically ten percent i don't advise trying to guess for most people to be
honest with you
i want to be cognizant of time as well because the thing is is your own news
like you see it
yesterday this was 28th 28th there was a whole bunch of your own news like two
forty five
but it doesn't have much of an impact it's it's it's us news that has the big
impact
but i don't even know if it tags us in it doesn't which is fine
yeah i'll probably read that wrong to be honest with you but it's fine
um i don't want to scale my entry and stuff as well to be honest
we can keep open
okay now close it yeah honestly like full transparency um probably a mess read
on my behalf
probably should have used the fair value up there's m five fair value up
instead of just trying the odd block itself
um more or should have reasons number one is the m five fair value up number
two is
not on the m3 it's on the m2 and m1 what i was looking for is this inverter
fair value up
this double lap over where you have a fair value gap that's inverted by another
do you have like a double inverted fair value up and you have it on the one
minute as well
where you have this fair value up inverted by a fair value up that's where you
want your entry
so just take note when you have that that's where you want your your entry
sometimes you might
still get tagged into the order block as well but that's what you really want
that's my mistake i'm not going to try and rectify it because it just it's
going to happen in the
life market as well listen does the thing you want to treat also your back
testing like a live
environment it's very easy to be in that scenario and then go back and change
it and be like oh
you know i could have used that but you're also going to have times in the life
market and it's
going to be good wrenching but it's also good to have that apart your data so
understand that your
data isn't perfect that there's still you know some human error you don't want
it to be
like drastic human error but something that's such a small detail like that i
don't mind leaving that
in something is literally drastic as you didn't take a trade even though it
fits your plan that
you need to go back and retake that trade which you've seen me do more
sometimes but something like
that where it's like a very nuanced believe it in your data you can take notes
of it if you want
for example like i understand that scenario 100 percent you're using the
inverted value gap you
have been talked about it before we'll exaggerate the reason that in areas
interesting is because of
that inverted value gap so yeah make sure you have that in there but that's all
the neural
news you can see it barely even moved priced so drastically then we come in for
new york
31st no news so we may end up getting a trade here as well because we have this
London area of interest that's shifted internal structure
if we break this high which we do then we could look at maybe continuations
from this
inverted value gap
don't like this low in here that's probably an unfinished option
one to three
extend it a little bit if we want
it's not really a little bit it's asking quite a lot to be totally honest
okay and so this would be basically London continuation with bullish we've had
a really
nice sweep of this we've had an internal you know internal structural shift
bullish
so internally bullish we're coming from you know kind of difficult from this
level strong
point of interest inside of London had an internal shift look it makes sense to
take it
we're tagged in
nine oh three or something another one
i want to watch this play out because i want to see how i would manage it
it's now attacked in
i'm going to check it out okay it's not really a way to manage it
and sometimes that's just that's just how it goes and i'm going to get tagged
in from there
nope
unfortunate price action and do we actually go for the highs?
no so this trade would have been a profit but not full take profit
this wouldn't have been a full take profit anyway um i don't want to call it
unfortunate but
a little bit of luck of fortune now but also very important that it does for
example the
light market because the reality is is that you're also going to get periods
where you get
lucky and unlucky in your execution to the thing like that so it's an important
so win rate is at 26% which is um 26% the things that brings us up if i'm not
mistaken
yeah we have a little bit of an increase in win rate
but look at this average win to loss portrayed this is the key difference right
so people obsess over win rate and win rate is important obviously but this
without without this your win rate is meaningless meaningless this month we've
taken hamley trades
six ten which is around about the average 15% return great month
15% return 33% win rate average win to lose in trade gives you an average of 9.
in other words that's like ridiculously profitable um
ridiculously profitable
and figure it out from a win rate perspective like with that type of average
win to lose in
lost trade ratio your win rate could be so low and you would still make money
so win rate alone is irrelevant 4.69 per factor really good month begins
bringing that average up
now we are sitting at 36.5% across February, March, April, May, June, July
six months 36.5% so what is that it's like a six a little bit over six 6.1 6.1
6.1 1 6 percent something like that per month so we're bringing our average up
which is good
we're going to bring it more in alignment with 2024 and 5 as well it's
unfortunate that
we did test
2024 the way we did to be honest I wish we didn't test 2024 with
a
compound honestly but it's not going to make a huge difference
so that's 2023 and 2025 so that's six months of 2023 and
I think four four months of 2025 so that's 10 months between 2023 and 2025
with an 80% return average of eight that's pretty much what you're going to
expect the
the day it to be as well consistently throughout like somewhere in the region
of
30 to 35% win rate which is solid with this type of risk reward system average
win to lost trade is 6.8 I know that I can get this I believe I can get this to
like a seven to eight
times average win to lose in trade with that one rule that implemented I just
need to make
sure and check that it doesn't ruin too many profits because that's the thing
you can see
something that occurs all the time in losing trades and you can think like oh I
could add this in
and reduce that but then you need to make sure that you don't by doing so
interfere with your
winners I think I can bring the win rate of the entire system higher anyway but
I don't think I
know I can bring the entire win rate of the system higher simply just by
removing some of the data
points but like to have the edge where it's at right now with you know we have
like a 33% win rate
across 20 months worth of data 200 trades 50 92 93 193 trades so 200 trades
which is more than enough to validate an edge 200 trades we are this is a
little bit difficult
because we don't actually know because of the end period of 2020 before
everything became kind of
doubled which is really annoying and our model pool is this data is just
completely wrong I think
like apparently it's got 11% trade win rate but I don't think this is wrong
the risk to reward 259 times risk
no it must be must be wrong
yeah I don't understand what how the our mobile works to be honest with you
because apparently there's just one trade here that's like 108 y'all I'm not
really sure how that
works um yeah I think it's
yeah I'm not sure
apparently we have 72% return on P&L which is also inaccurate
we're a hundred ninety two trades that's inaccurate
does completely inaccurate
cool you can see here look this is the 2024 period where you can see the the
spikes in losses
were a lot higher that's because we were doing cumulative risk
you can see up to like the middle of 2024 it was pretty okay
but here it just started getting wild
how do we lose
some one day
was up on week
I'm not sure why that looks like that
Um, okay, I won't spend too much time faffing around with the data, let's keep
it moving.